star wars fans are reacting to the new
lego star wars dlc and halo fans aren't
too thrilled with the new battle rifle
changes
in celebration of may 4th aka star wars
day wb games have launched two new dlc
packs for lego star wars the skywalker
saga one of the packs the mandalorian
season 2 features characters like ahsoka
boba fett and moff gideon the other pack
star wars the bad batch features
characters like hunter wrecker tech
crosshair and echo players can purchase
these new packs separately or they can
grab the character collection pack which
includes mando season 1 solo a star wars
story rogue one and more fans of the
game reacted to the new dlc trailer and
expressed some interest in more than
just new characters in the youtube
comments users said things like quote
now what i need are story dlcs i play
through clone wars and the mandalorian
for example dlcs with new story missions
will be incredible over on reddit users
seem to have a similar opinion and said
things like quote those are just
characters no new missions or planets a
bit of a letdown yeah i feel like
initial marketing indicated at a minimum
rogue one and solo would get story
content so overall it seems like fans
have their fingers crossed for both
clone wars and story missions in some
form or another hit the comments of this
video and let me know what you're hoping
for personally i was hoping for the game
to go on sale today but i guess it's too
soon for that tomorrow makes a full
month since the game actually released
not to mention the game has also sold
incredibly well becoming the biggest
launch in the history of the lego series
selling through 3.2 million units over
its first two weeks another game that
features wars in space is halo and a
ranked only melee buff for the battle
rifle in halo infinite season 2 has not
gone over very well with fans the buff
for the battle rifles melee in the
ranked playlist essentially keeps the
weapon performing as it was in season 1
following the otherwise universal 10
melee damage reduction introduced as a
part of season 2. the patch notes state
the battle rifle's melee damage was kept
intact and ranked in order to preserve
the battle rifle's two burst beatdown
after the global melee reduction it's
also important to note that all players
start with a battle rifle in ranked fans
by and large don't seem to be thrilled
with the battle rifle change having a
weapon that performs differently and
ranked as opposed to other playlists
players on the halo infinite subreddit
argue that having a weapon that performs
differently in ranked as opposed to all
other playlists makes the game more
confusing and punishing for players who
jump in between different playlists
frequently the move seems to cater to
the game's more competitive community
who would be upset if the battle rifle
receives significant changes but in the
process upset the game's more casual
audience many fans are wondering why 343
didn't simply add the melee damage buff
to the battle rifle in social playlists
as well and in other online shooter news
apex legends might start releasing
characters slower in a new interview the
game's senior character designer devin
maguire explained that while apex
legends is more about movement and
firearms than legend abilities those
abilities can still unbalance the game
as it becomes more difficult to create
characters who are unique without being
too overpowered or niche with each
passing season maguire explained that
the game may reach a breaking point
where adding a new legend every season
may become detrimental to the game
itself saying quote whether or not that
pattern continues is an ongoing
discussion and it might not be changed
but we don't want to saturate the pool
of legends so what do you think about
this would you mind if they slowed down
the release of legends and what other
games do you think should slow down with
the release of characters